salut nous sommes en plein coeur des
énigmes d'élite et cette petite série
que j'ai créé une énigme par jour
pendant 32 jours à l'intérieur du défi
du mental blog avant de vous donner
l'énigme d'aujourd'hui la réponse à
l'énigme d'hier comme d'habitude si vous
n'avez pas vu l'énigme et dire regardez
là avant puisque l'âge donne la réponse
ça tient grâce à deux choses assez
subtil mais pourtant réel js est né le
31 décembre donc c'est vrai mon pote js
est né le 31 décembre et le moment on
formule l'énigme on est le 1er janvier
donc le 1er janvier il a 18 ans
avant-hier il avait bien 17 ans
puisqu'on était le 30 décembre
cette année en cours l'année dont parle
année du 1er janvier il leur a donc 19
ans à la fin de l'année et donc l'année
prochaine il aura bien 20 ans c'est pour
ça que ça fonctionne c'est tout à fait
possible qu'avant-hier et les u17 en est
un et prochaine il est vain peut-être
que vous trouvez ça tordu aujourd'hui
vous allez pouvoir c'est beaucoup moins
tordu je pense énigmes 19 et digbeu
mathématiques ça fait un petit moment
que je n'ai pas fait de mal comme ça
dans les énigmes
alors ça se trouve on n'y a pas de
calcul compliqué c'est plutôt le
raisonnement est la logique qu'il faut
avoir 6 800 poules pondent 800 e
en huit jours combien duff sont pondus
par 400 poule en quatre jours je répète
6 800 pour le pont de 800 e
en huit jours combien deux ponts de 400
poule en quatre jours et la réponse est
simple c'est demain que je vous le
donnerai comme tous les jours bah oui
évidemment dès que vous trouvez la
réponse faites le moi savoir 1 laissant
un pouce en l'air que je vois le nombre
de personnes qui ont trouvé la réponse à
cette énigme profiter du soleil de la
plage de tout ce que vous voulez en tout
cas passer un bel été bon courage
peut-être à ceux qui bossent en ce
moment n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
avant de partir voire même de partager
une énigme de temps en temps sur votre
page facebook
par exemple parce que le mental blog
c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
donc rendez vous demain à 17h ciao